the Apple watch Ultra is here and it's
not only the biggest redesign to the
Apple watch ever but it packs a ton of
extra features and changes some of which
Apple didn't mention during their event
and the best question going around
concerning the new Ultra is whether it's
actually worth upgrading from one of the
previous models regardless of whether
it's the series 7 the 6 the 5 or even
the four so that's precisely what I'm
gonna be answering in this video helping
you decide if you should buy it or skip
it and before we begin it's important to
familiarize yourself with the new
features that are coming to the new
series 8. before we jump into the
exclusive features changes and tidbits
about the ultra so let's get started the
series a is probably one of the smallest
updates I've seen in years with
literally only two changes compared to
the series 7 the new crash detection
feature and the new body temperature
sensors for women's ovulation tracking
that's it even the new S8 chip is
literally just a rebranded S7 which was
already just a rebranded S6 and it's
still stuck with Bluetooth 5.0 compared
to 5.3 on the iPhone 14. but the Apple
watch Ultra on the other hand does in
fact get Bluetooth 5.3 and a bunch of
exclusive features never before seen on
any previous Apple watch so let's jump
right into those before I explain if
it's worth upgrading the new Ultra of
course comes with a brand new design
with a strong yet lightweight titanium
49 millimeter casing which features a
new protruding Crown guard on the right
side a total of three microphones with
beam forming for a better vocal Clarity
and wind resistance a new dual speaker
setup that's 40 louder than the one in
the series 8 to support an absolutely
killer 86 decibel siren feature which
can be heard up to 600 feet away a brand
new customizable action button on the
left side and of course an even larger
sapphire crystal display that's now
finally completely flat and protected by
the raised edge of the casing instead of
being rounded and exposed like the other
Apple watch models and the ultra is
definitely thick sitting at 14.4
millimeters compared to 10.7 on the
other models which is 35 percent thicker
but that's mostly because it literally
gets double the battery life compared to
the other models 36 hours compared to
18. that battery life difference alone
is gonna make people want to upgrade to
the ultra and I'm not even joking and
even with that huge two times Battery
and 35 thickness difference it's only 19
percent heavier than the stainless steel
series 8 because of the lightweight
titanium material and not only is the
display now five percent bigger at 1.99
inches compared to 1.9 on the 45
millimeter series 8 but the always on
display is now up to two times brighter
at a massive two thousand nits compared
to a thousand on the series 8 which
means it'll be easily visible in direct
sunlight and not only that but it comes
with a new night mode for low visibility
conditions which I've got to say is
really cool and in terms of pixel
density it features 44 more pixels than
the original iPhone's display on your
wrist to make the brand new exclusive
wayfinder watch face look even bigger
and better and honestly this watch face
alone might convince some people to
upgrade and even with the larger 49
millimeter case size you can still reuse
the same old bands that were supported
on the 42 through 45 millimeter Apple
watch models as well as the three brand
new Ultra bands including the Trail Loop
the Alpine Loop and The Ocean band but
now let's get into what actually makes
the ultra so special but first I've got
to give a shout out to our sponsor grid
Studio who takes what would have been
E-Waste and turn it into art like the
original iPad Mini fully disassembled
and framed and starting now through the
11th grid is doing a special flash sale
with amazing deals on the iPhone 4S the
Game Boy Pocket the iPhone classic kit
and the Nintendo classic kit frames and
since it's Grid's two-year anniversary
those ordering between now and the 11th
could win limited edition prices like
the iPad 1 or MacBook airframes a
special badge collection or a t-shirt so
check out the link below now getting
back to what makes the Apple watch Ultra
so special the extreme weatherproof
design allowing it to maintain proper
operation in environments ranging from
negative 4 degrees to 131 degrees
Fahrenheit helping it achieve its 810 H
military standard rating which yes is
used by the military to make sure their
gear can handle extreme environments and
on top of that it's water resistant
rated up to the en 13319 diving standard
which is basically the highest rating
for snorkeling high-speed water sports
and scuba diving all the way down to 130
feet below the surface coming with both
a depth gauge and a water temperature
sensor which is really cool as well as
the exclusive Oceanic plus diving app
making it a certified diving computer
with it being water resistant up to 100
meters compared to 50 on the other Apple
watch models and making it even better
the ultra Now features Precision dual
frequency GPS for Pinpoint location
tracking accuracy since L5 GPS is the
latest and greatest GPS signal available
to civilians helping the new Waypoint
marking and backtracking feature within
the redesigned compass work the best and
as an added bonus to all of that you
also get a new exclusive braided charger
in the Box to complete the premium feel
alongside the completely unique
outdoorsy packaging so with all that
said and out of the way it's time to get
into the question of if you should
actually upgrade to the ultra from a
previous Apple watch so let's get right
into that probably the most impressive
part about the Apple watch Ultra is the
fact that it's only 799 dollars while
coming with a premium titanium casing
and cellular already built in which is
kind of shocking because the previous 45
millimeter Series 7 model with a
titanium casing started at 849 dollars
even more expensive than the ultra and
to think that you're now getting a
larger 49 millimeter casing the new
redesign with an even more protected
display that is now twice as bright
literally double the battery life and
many other upgrades and features all for
less cash than a clearly inferior Series
7 model and not only that but I specced
up a new smaller 41 millimeter series 8
stainless steel model for my wife and
couldn't believe it ended up being 750
dollars only 50 bucks less than the
ultra so it actually ordered her an
ultra and planned to cancel the series
8. so in my opinion if you were thinking
of finally upgrading to one of the
series 8 models and choosing a nicer
metal material you should honestly just
buy the ultra instead if you care about
value however there is a bit of a caveat
and that's the fact that the ultra looks
absolutely massive on smaller wrists
like iJustine showed off at Apple's
events and that alone could be a deal
breaker for some people like my wife who
told me she didn't want a massive Apple
watch Ultra despite all of the extra
features and battery life so I guess I'm
just gonna end up keeping it for myself
so if you don't mind the big 49
millimeter casing I would recommend
upgrading hands down especially if
you're someone who really cares about
battery life that 36 hour battery alone
will seal the deal especially if you're
upgrading from an older Apple watch like
the series four or five where your
battery is likely getting old already
and there are even more feature changes
going up to the new Ultra and in my
honest opinion I feel like the ultra
combined with the way finder watch face
looks really unique and actually looks
more like a stylish high-end watch than
the pretty basic apple watches of the
past so if you're all about style the
ultra is where it's at and of course if
you do any type of sports and care about
that aspect of the watch you should 100
be buying this model if you can the only
reason I wouldn't recommend the ultra is
if you really don't care about having
cellular service the higher end titanium
material compared to aluminum or any of
the other feature and in that case you
can save a lot of money by going with
the 400 series 8 or even a renewed
Series 7 for as low as 320 on Amazon
using the link below but with all that
said what it all comes down to is this
the Apple watch Ultra is for people who
like the Apple watch and want the best
version that's it case closed so if
that's you you should definitely upgrade
to the ultra and let me know your
thoughts on if you're upgrading and
which model you're upgrading from down
in the comment section below definitely
check out the link below for the grid
Studio frames with the flash sale and
click subscribe because we are going to
be covering these new watches and the
ultra in detail very soon so definitely
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign